hey guys merry here with the game spot
news update shortly after the free
playstation plus edition of ps4 racing
game drive club was released on the
PlayStation Store they took it down as
the name suggests you'll need a
PlayStation Plus subscription in order
to download and play this free version
of the game you'll also need a time
machine because as of now they've
already removed it from the PlayStation
Store we've reached out to Sony for
comment and we'll let you know what they
say driveclub PlayStation Plus Edition
offers a mix of single and multiplayer
content according to the PSN listing it
offers every driveclub feature including
online multiplayer matches and
challenges to offline solo racing tour
events customization replays photo mode
and more it also contains 13 of India's
tracks 15 cars and 27 trophies including
the platinum as the name suggests you'll
need a PlayStation Plus subscription in
order to download and play the free
version of the game driveclub and its
accompanying Free Edition were
originally slated to be alongside the
ps4 back in 2013 before being pushed
back almost a full year to october 2014
when the full game launched with serious
issues the plus editions release was
delayed indefinitely despite this
extended wait Sony repeatedly insisted
that the version was not cancelled when
developer evolution studios was hit with
layoffs in March Sony claimed it would
now focus on Drive club as a service
going forward in particular most
important launch of the PS Plus edition
so unfortunately the free playstation
plus edition of driveclub has already
been taken down but because of this we
can assume that driveclub is probably
officially about to be released for the
latest on driveclub be sure to head
gamespot com
you